my channel is sponsored by epic games
and full guys which means we'll have an
ad from them somewhere in the middle
hello everyone a few weeks ago at summer
game fest i got to try the samsung
gaming hub specifically the xbox app um
which basically is or at least my
experience with it was
turning on a samsung tv
you know using your little smart remote
to select xbox uh in the gaming hub
which is something that um i believe
comes pre-installed on the samsung tvs
it's compatible with and we will have
way more factual information towards the
end of this video because i did an
interview uh with somebody who actually
worked on it um
booted up
uh an interface that looked a lot like
an xbox
and immediately jumped into playing
psychonauts ii um virtually
instantaneously i did a whole bunch of
jumps and levitating and all the crazy
stuff i could to see if i could get any
latency and to me uh it was completely
imperceptible um i will say
the image was pixelated in a number of
places and i had that while i played
halo as well but these are event
conditions it's pretty terrible and it's
also this is for something i didn't have
to download uh it's something that was
instantaneous something that i could not
detect any latency i didn't have any
trouble playing halo obviously i wanted
to try that as an fps i did not notice
any lag at all which is wild i'm sure
some exist no latency is very difficult
but none that i could perceive
and
that experience was very very very
impressive to me and from everyone else
that i know who went to the event and
also got to try it were also very
impressed by it i guess the idea
again we'll have more info at the rest
of this video is that
people without consoles
will be able to stream games just to
samsung tvs
um you don't have to buy
an xbox to play psychonauts 2 or halo
infant or even to get achievements
because they said you are still able to
unlock achievements all you have to do
is have that app
generally comes pre-installed i believe
and load it up so that you can jump
straight into video games without
download times without that expensive
barrier to entry and i don't necessarily
think uh that this is for
console gamers people who already have
consoles with some exceptions i think
this is probably more for audiences who
aren't necessarily already in that
infrastructure or people who just don't
want to
download a new game and still want to
play it so i was very impressed by it um
again the image was definitely a little
bit muddy a little bit pixelated uh in
some places the details are all still
there uh you could see what was
happening just some pixels that you
don't have when you've actually got the
game installed on hardware and that's
been my experience with game streaming
through xcloud as well i often use
backbone and play games on my phone from
both playstation and xbox and i feel
like that pixelation is not uncommon
so it did feel like this is in pretty
early stages it is not out yet
but i found it impressive and so did
want to talk about it and answer some
questions about it uh so that you guys
get some insight into what it actually
is so
now let's jump to
an interview this is with mike lucaro uh
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
enjoy just want to note before the
interview starts that mike did
occasionally get some notifications so
you will hear that as part of the audio
apologies for that everyone this is mike
who is the head of product for gaming
for samsung tvs who is here to talk to
me about the samsung xbox gaming hub is
that am i saying that title correctly
uh yes okay actually it's amazon gaming
hub but xbox is one of your partners
probably our biggest partner but we have
others as well so okay good to know so
first things first for anyone who is
totally unfamiliar with what this is
who's never heard of it what exactly is
it
so the samsung gaming hub is basically
where all things gaming are in one place
um we we realized um a few years ago
that gaming is the biggest form of
entertainment out there and you know
bigger than music movies tv sports list
goes on and on yeah oh the stuff that
all of us gamers know and our execs
realize wait a minute we're not we're
under serving the gaming um sort of
members of our audience so we decided to
make gamers first class citizens
essentially create a virtual console
that brings all things gaming
whether it's your game streaming or your
consoles or your you know twitch and
youtube videos
your music spotify brings that all
together in one place and so the gaming
hub is kind of a one-stop shop for all
things gaming you all you need is your
own controller that you compare can be a
playstation controller it can be an xbox
controller it can be you know any number
of third-party controllers um doesn't
matter which service you're on you can
play you know xbox with a playstation
controller for example so it's really
it's trying to reduce friction from the
tv and just make it as easy to watch or
play games as it is to watch you know a
netflix video or hulu video i mean
conceptually it is kind of similar right
what what the the big take away from
this and the thing that you know really
impressed me about it was that it is
game streaming
like you have a console without ever
needing to buy a console it is it is
sort of like the video game version of
netflix was that the intent
yeah i mean it's sort of i mean that
that each of the apps is certainly one
of those experiments you know we've got
several different business models
supported in our apps summer
subscriptions some arguments for you
know you buy titles individually
um
but in general it's like you know all
we're trying to get as many uh games and
sort of purchase types as possible just
to make it as so gamers can have the
choice of what they want to buy some
people want to buy games let them buy
games some people want to do a
subscription which is more like the
netflix bottle let's let them do that
and in general it's like people
everybody has their own sort of way they
like the game and some people like
consoles you know we don't we're fine
with consoles also we just want
everything to be seamless
and in one sort of great gamer oriented
experience i mean it feels a lot like a
console there's a look and feel we've
got a bunch of you know former um
console people on the team so it should
very it should feel very natural to
people that are used to consoles but
should also feel very open to all those
other gamers that either can't afford a
console or they have one console but
they don't want to buy the other console
et cetera et cetera so
just a you know single simple place to
do all things gaming and it's again it's
not just about playing games it's also
about participating in the community you
know watching twitch youtube etc um
we're you know and offering more and
more um you know services over time you
know we launched with um you know with
with geforce now with stadia and utomik
and then we made the big xbox
announcement and you know now we're done
now we're announcing uh with launch that
luna you know from amazon is there which
is super exciting um and you know twitch
is going to be there as well as
including and also spotify for music
because we we know that people like to
do all these things when they play games
i mean that's been a feature on consoles
for years is being able to listen to
your music so we have that also so we're
trying to just bring things that we know
gamers love when they play games and put
it all in one place a lot of convenience
a lot of convenience
uh so i did get to try playing a number
of xbox games at summer game fest a few
weeks ago a few months ago i don't even
know what time is anymore um i jumped
i jumped between psychonauts and halo
infinite um
and from
my experience and that was at a public
event where things tend to go wrong i
did not have any detectable latency
whatsoever which i was very very very
impressed by um it was pretty familiar
looking dashboard just hit psychonauts 2
i start in the middle of a level i'm
playing as raz
and then i just close it jump over to um
playing halo infinite like i was so
impressed by how fast that was and i
just wanted to get i guess the simplest
terms of how this tech actually works um
because it blew my mind that it was
that simple i imagine years of work went
into making this function this way
so true and that's really what it comes
down to it's like you know
this you know
every member
of the ecosystem that sort of
participates in that chain basically
what you're seeing is you push a button
and it goes to a server simmer and then
comes back and it needs to all happen
you know virtually instantly
and you know we've done our some heavy
lifting on our side with the tv you know
we basically every step along the way
sort of adds um you know latency to the
to the equation yeah so
you want to you know for example you
know between the bluetooth controller
and the tv you want to have that as
short a distance as pos possible and we
worked with each of the partners to make
that as short as possible then within
the tv itself you know we take that we
have a thing called game mode that takes
30 of the
on device latency out of the equation so
that's quite a few milliseconds and then
you know all of our partners including
xbox has done an amazing job on the back
end on the infrastructure side as well
so you know every step of the way we
have and we have we have have very high
standards
as do our partners you know we put a
very firm stake in the ground needs to
hit a certain mark from a performance
perspective and we had to meet that mark
and that's why we didn't announce xbox
until until you know summer game fast
because we weren't ready because we want
to make sure it was a great experience
and i'm thrilled to hear that you for
for us that's the the biggest praise
that you know that you it's almost
imperceptible for the sort of the
average gamer and you know hearing that
from someone like you just
you have a pretty uh well
respected position in the gaming
business so for someone like you to
appreciate that is really special for me
and the team it is time to talk about
full guys which is game we've been
playing since launch maybe since before
launch and i think my community's raised
something like fifty thousand maybe a
hundred thousand dollars even
all while i've been playing four guys if
you didn't already know four guys can
now be downloaded and played for free
across playstation nintendo switch xbox
and the epic game store though i do want
to note that there are optional in-game
items for purchase with this launch
which is on june 21st i've already
played it and enjoyed it there's a new
season of fall guys full guys free for
all with new rounds and shows costumes
ever evolving gameplay and importantly
it's also cross platform and cross
progression that means you keep your
account and your inventory across
platforms and it means you can play with
your friends who are on different
consoles who play on pc basically an
already very big very accessible game
got bigger and more accessible for
players like me who previously purchased
four guys before june 21st you also get
a new legacy pack with a host of goodies
including a veggie dog costume feisty
dwarf costume and a season pass for
season one so what are you waiting for
you can play four guys for free
right now if you check out the link in
the description it might even be my
foster dog's favorite game look at him
how could you not support this strapping
young man
all he wants you to do is download and
play fall guys for free across all
platforms using the link in the
description huge thanks to epic games
and fall guys for sponsoring this video
now back to the video i i guess latency
is obviously a big focus what else do
you feel like is important for making
sure that you hit that bar so that
gamers don't feel like they're playing
something that's sluggish or slow or
doesn't feel right
sure well the other thing is obviously
picture quality yeah yeah up scaling so
even though we get a 1080p
um stream from you know for most of our
partners uh not all we actually get 4k
from some of them as well but you know
we get a certain stream from each of the
partners and then our our processor
actually upscales that um to make it
look you know 4k so or 8k um so that's
another um important thing because you
know the responsiveness and richness of
picture quality
um and along with also the refresh rate
that really makes those textures come to
life very quickly and feel very real um
those are all the things that really
make it immersive and you know the real
game critics will take a look at that
and we've been pleasantly surprised that
you know you you're in forza doing
donuts and they'll let the donuts look
like they should
the the dirt doing its dirt thing so
particles
particles
uh so one thing that i think is very
important to ask in relation to all of
that like how how the quality is
represented for me could be very
different to somebody in a different
state i was here in los angeles what are
the internet requirements how accessible
do you think this is globally that's a
great question uh and obviously there's
um you know different quality levels
around the country but
we have optimized for you know a what we
consider a pretty standard um internet
connection uh 20
megabits per second in the home which is
a pretty standard consumer grade is that
still standard that sounds so slow
i know that's the thing well it's not
about
that's you know that that's the norm
these days and that's that's what i mean
internet's gotten better and better over
the years um or 5g wireless
also will work um so those are the kind
of the the men bars in terms of the
performance requirements but that's
pretty standard and the funny thing is
like you mentioned you know in a we've
done demos in hotel rooms and convention
centers those are always actually higher
risk than if we do stuff in people's
homes yeah and home
actually much safer to do good demos but
those big convention spaces and hotel
spaces
it's uh it's riskier and even in those
places we had a pretty good pretty good
performance so yeah i think i have 500
megs on my wi-fi
oh my god
yeah i just had to buy on your router
for that actually so that it would go up
to 500 i don't know that it ever does
but that's what i have and thinking of
20 it's like oh that that actually is
very accessible uh is this available
globally or are there global plans like
what regions uh is it available in
currently or will it be available in
yeah that's a great question so the
gaming hub itself will be launching in
nine countries so us canada brazil
um and then also in um
in the eu five as we're calling which is
uk france germany spain italy uh
yeah so those are the and free will have
obviously the most killer
internet because they have insane
internet over there so
imperceptible latency there but all
those countries support it
and the partners themselves will
actually be in many more markets uh i
think xbox specifically
um will be in 28 markets i need to
perhaps fact check that we've just added
argentina and new zealand to the list um
that was part of the announcement at the
summer game fest
so you know it's going to be we're we're
going to be and you know nvidia's in
many many more markets they're in like
quite a you know it's
it's scores and scores of markets shall
we say um that they're in so
and in each case you know we've
partnered with these companies because
they have done the research to make sure
that the service will work in those
markets
so um you know they're kind of our
litmus test that you know obviously in
each case they have to
their app has to be certified by us
which means they meet the requirements
so we're kind of the quality control
mechanism if you will
um but they are you know they have done
the hard work which is making sure their
services are actually um quality in
those in those markets i imagine there
are plans for future rollouts to expand
beyond the nine that you are launching
on
yeah we just want we don't i will almost
i i do want to say this which is this is
our first foray into gaming you know
i've been in the gaming industry for a
while but i was a xbox live team member
i did quite a few things there i was at
twitch so i've been around for a while
and you know for samsung this is our
first foray into gaming and we want to
you know it's you know we i was on the
original xbox so i know how hard it can
be if you you know if you if if you
think you've got it right we're gonna
you know we want to be humble about it
and listen and learn along the way we're
great we're standing on the shoulders of
giants in terms of our partners
so we're lucky to have these great
partners to be working with but um you
know we're
we so in that in it to answer your
question that's why we're launching in
nine markets so we can make sure that
we're ready to go to you know a broader
set of markets that we'll go to as soon
as we're ready to hopefully sooner
that makes sense um as for tvs
specifically is there a limit on what
samsung tvs this will work on does it
work on older models is it available to
everybody like people who already own
samsung tvs which ones will have the app
and which one
yep no super important question that's
that's also uh you know very important
in terms of our considerations for how
we
um how we built it and we wanted to make
it as available as many of our tvs as
possible as broad range as possible so
if it's a 2022 tv
this the gaming hub will be available on
that
now it has to be we we have it's kind of
nuanced in terms of what is a 2022 tv
it's basically a chassis that we yeah we
update every year um and that's you know
that has certain chipset and certain
performance capabilities it has to be a
true 2022 tv
um so but yeah all those will support it
and you know we
obviously our partners for for our
partners it's important to have the apps
um on as many tvs as possible so we will
be announcing
sort of when how far back that will go
at a later time but we definitely want
to make sure that other partners apps
and customers can also experience them
on older tvs but we haven't made any
announcements on that yet and obviously
going forward we'll continue to
improve the gaming hub over time as well
yeah i think you've now answered all of
my like back-to-back factual questions
sorry if that felt like grilling um i
just wanted to ask what are you most
excited about what do you think is the
most exciting thing about
releasing this
well to be honest you know what what's
the most exciting we didn't really talk
about this as sort of a fundamental
consumer benefit but i don't know how
much time you spend sort of
game streaming but you know it's the
ability to you know i've been obviously
playing through all of our partner apps
over the last you know pretty much
non-stop and i'm even even when i'm on
the phone i'm sometimes the video is off
and i'm playing games
and it's the fact that we can really
you can just jump between services you
can jump between titles the fact that
there's no download required yeah
there's
there's no um it's it's so seamless i
mean the fact that you just switched
from game to game that gets like you're
in the mood for sites psychonauts one
second then you want to do halo then
it's pre-installed too right the app is
pre-installed yeah some of them are not
all public some of them are so
everything is so instant i mean it's
just shocking how how instant everything
is and i think the fact that you're not
there's games that i've always wanted to
play that i haven't played because i
don't want to i haven't freed up the
memory on my hard drive so the fact that
i don't have to do that anymore has
opened up just a
vast number of new games that i would
ordinarily you know there's i just
started playing hades which is
and it's just i just haven't been able
to make room for it and i just there was
and i said you know i'm gonna play it
there i was playing hades that's a great
point like as somebody who has all the
consoles i can still see myself swapping
over to this
when i don't want to download halo
infinite like well i don't have to let
me just do it over here like that's uh
definitely um something that's going to
appeal to a lot of people who don't want
to download something that's 90 gigs
just to play something exactly and have
to take you know take call of duty off
every time
these are just such large video games no
the instantaneousness was definitely
what what
impressed me the most um mike you know
you mentioned that you started out not
started out necessarily but that you
worked on xbox live back in the day and
now we're at this instantaneous
streaming era like do you think this is
the future of video games is this is
this where we're all headed now i think
it's a future i mean i think people
always consoles will always be
have an important role in the ecosystem
i mean just look at nintendo you know
they're
they they continue to sort of redefine
the business based on innovation around
constant i think i think every sort of
distribution
platform kind of pushes the other
distribution platforms to do something
better so for me it's more a reflection
of how gaming pushes the industry and
it's like you know what this is going to
be a smackdown with the console uh
manufacturers that's great we've got
fortunately xbox is is on on that does
both sides of that but you know it's
like let's let's challenge the the um
the console makers to do something more
innovative and then they'll challenge us
to be more innovative i just think
that's the beauty of the gaming industry
is that we're always pushing pushing
pushing and it's just not as linear as
other forms of entertainment it's true
yeah we all learn from each other it's
it's it's so much you know just
iteration collaborative iteration for
sure um which i guess related did you
look at other similar streaming services
like stadia and were there any lessons
that you felt to learn from things like
that
yeah i mean
we i think we all learned from stadia
that
um you want to launch when you're ready
to launch yeah and you want to just you
know there's nothing wrong i mean
as far as i know the game the xbox app
is still in beta xcloud is still in beta
you know it's like don't be don't exit
out of beta too quickly yeah and don't
be afraid to have a beta i mean
we're in unchartered territory here so
you can sort of put a label on it to
make sure that you are going to take
that off when it's ready and there's
there's no need to take it off too soon
i mean the industry is very
very sort of um
that you have permission to do that so i
you know i feel and some of our partners
have chosen to do that and that's great
that's that's upon our recommendation
players also know if something's not
ready they'll call it a beta even if you
don't so you might as well do it
yourself
um is there anything else that you
wanted to share mike oh sorry i was
talking about it go ahead
it's something that's new to samsung as
well
doing doing betas is something we're not
it's not really in our dna
and you know bringing the company along
um is
you know is is important you know we
again this goes back to sort of the uh
humility and gaming and we're very lucky
to be uh in this space with these great
partners and um we don't take any of
that for granted so um we're just glad
that we can sort of have a seat at the
table or at least a small seat or the
probably the the kids table right now
but we want to you know we're here to
stay and i'm so glad to hear that they
have you though like having somebody who
actually has a background in gaming i
think that's where a lot of these
companies can go or miss
they think they understand what gamers
want they think they understand the
market and just completely misfire so
that's obviously important and i'm glad
that it seems like samsung is taking
that seriously too yeah haven't they
have they've surrounded me with a great
team i've got a team
of um you know partners that have
both inside and outside the company that
have you know allowed us to build the
right
um sort of launch um platform to you
know to to come on so um they have
really i commend samsung for
having let us do this right yeah and
again i i've warned them a million times
we're gonna make a ton of mistakes we're
going to probably take a bunch of heat
on launch day but we're going to be her
ears are open and we'll listen and
correct and learn and hopefully everyone
come on the journey with us together
that is great to hear and again
i played it at a as a demo at an event
and i was already very impressed so
i think you might be better off than
you'd even imagine it was it was like a
highlight for a lot of people there
talking about how cool it was and how
yeah seamless it was very very
impressive so easy to operate like
almost every question that i asked the
person who was doing my demo was like
can i do this do i still get
achievements does this work and it was
all yes which is just super exciting so
yeah the the partners done such a great
job of thinking every aspect of the user
experience through um s has my team in
terms of the user interface for the
gaming hub itself so those two bring
those two together i think will
hopefully make us at least um you know
have a a good uh jump out of the gates
in the next
in the next few days i um understand if
you can't fully answer this question but
uh should we expect
partnerships with more of the
hardware developers other than xbox
well i mean right now we're focusing on
launch um you know obviously over time
we're going to continue to bring more
content partners into into the fold um
we're excited about who we have as
launch partners and that's what we're
focusing on right now it's a very good
pr answer success
um for the question i asked before that
i really cut you off from was there
anything else that you wanted to share
are there anything that we've missed
here that you really want to make sure
people know no you've been very generous
and asking the right questions i think
the most important thing is around the
humility and really i want to like put
my email out there for anybody who has
feedback to you know to provide it i
would let the reddit forums know let
everybody know we really really really
want to listen we know we have a lot to
learn so i want you to you know i want
the entire community to to give us their
feedback and make sure we just continue
to improve
that is awesome to hear i imagine you
will get plenty of it if i know the
internet
god
all right thank you so much for chatting
me mike um i look forward to trying it
out at home yep i look forward to you
getting your tv and just you know
playing some multiplayer halo super
exciting thanks for watching bye
yeah
thanks to epic games and full guys for
sponsoring the video check the link in
the description